字幕: Chika Mizuta
校正: Hiroko Kawano
みなさんこんにちは 阿部公彦と申します
「TED Talks」 というと
ノリノリのお客さんに支えられて
ノリノリのスピーカーが
流暢に 楽しそうに
そしてすごく良い話をすると
そういうイメージが あるかもしれません
しかし今回 このコロナのこともあって
私はこのように カメラの前で
一人でブツブツ陰気に喋るという
そういう設定になってしまいました
がっかりしてる人もいるかと思います
ただせっかくなので
あえてこういう機会でなければ
なかなか話題にできないようなことを
お話をしてみたいなと思っています
それは TED Talks そのものを
話題にするということ
つまり 言ってみれば
今回の聴衆は TED Talksそのものです
もともと私はちょっとこのTED Talksに対して
気になることがあったので
その気になることを
今回のイベントでぶつけてみたいと
そういうふうに思っています
よろしくお願いします
私は 文学の研究をしています
文学の研究者というものは
人が悪ければ悪いほど 良いとされている
優れているとされることがあるんですね
で そういう意味では 私は人が良すぎて
まだまだヒヨッコだなというふうに思ってます
なんで文学の研究をしている人は
人が悪いのかというと
文学というのがそもそも
みんなが左を向いている時には 右を見たり
右を向いている時には
左を見たりするというような
そういう衝動に支えられているからなんですね
まあ言ってみれば 天邪鬼です
そういう面倒臭い性格を持てればこそ
文学というものは活性化させることが
できるというふうに考えられています
そのおかげで 文学は
変なものとか 逸脱したものとか
規格に合わないものを
すくい上げることができるんですね
だから 文学に関わる研究者にしても
作家や詩人にしても
例えば人が前を向いている時には
後ろを見るとか
人が天を見上げている時には
むしろ 奈落の底をうかがうぐらいの
そういう気持ちがあると ちょうど良いと
そういうことになるわけですね
で 先ほどお話ししたように
TED Talksというのは
ノリノリのお客さんの前で
ノリノリの弁士が流暢に喋るという
イベントとして考えられていますけれども
そういうTED Talksの場であえて私は
「人前でそんなにペラペラ
上手に喋るのが良いことですか」
という疑問を問いかけたいと
そういうふうに思っています
このところ
人前でペラペラ喋れるのはすごく良いことだ
という考えが皆さんに共有されていて
例えば 中学とか高校でも
プレゼンの練習というのを
しばしばさせられますし
あるいは 大学のAO入試なんかでは
雄弁に喋れる人が 確実に有利になります
大学入試の英語でも —
その延長上なんだと思いますけれども —
英語の喋るテストをしよう
ということが唱えられるようになって
そこで喋るテストをするなら
それは民間試験でしょうということで
民間試験業者の方が攻勢をかけて
一気に 大学入試を民営化しよう
という話まで出てきました
で まぁ この大学入試改革は
結局 失敗したわけですけれども
ただ みなさん何となく
例えば 「英語ペラペラになったら良いよね」
というような考えは
今でも持っていると思います
で こういう 例えば英語で言えば
「少しでも流暢に喋れたら良いな」
という考えと
人前で喋れるのは良いことだ
っていうような考えは
どちらもおそらく
西洋文化への憧れのようなものと
関係しているんじゃないかというふうに
私は思っていますが
そこで私はあえて
人前でそんなにペラペラ喋る
ということが立派なことですか？
大事なことですか？ 良いことですか？
ということを問いかけてみたいと
そういうふうに思っています
私の父親は元々商社に勤めていて
長らく北米のいくつかの都市で
勤務をしていました
その関係で 私も５歳までは
カナダのバンクーバーという所に
住んでいたんですね
この頃は保育園、幼稚園に通い
それから近所の友達とも
結構 よく遊んでいたので
言葉の中心は英語だったんですね
ところが 日本に帰ってきて
環境が一変します
全て 日本語になってしまったわけですね
それで面白いのが
この頃のことって
ほとんど覚えてないんですね
その前のこと 帰国する前のことは
覚えているのに
何故かその時のことが
記憶から消えてしまったと
これはどうも
その後 両親に聞かされた話とも
ちょっと 関係しているのかなぁと
思っています
それは どういうことかというと
どうもこの時期 私がほとんど口を
きかなくなってしまった
喋れなくなったって言うんですね
あまりに喋らないので 心配して
病院に連れて行こうかと
思ったほどだったと聞いています
後で聞くと そういう
同じような経験をした人がいるらしくて
環境が激変して 喋らなくなってしまった
と同時に そのときのことを
ほとんど覚えていないと
そういうことが やっぱりあるそうなんですね
その時に私が思ったのは
人間の思考とか記憶というのが
すごく言葉に依存しているということですね
つまり日本に帰ってきたとき私は
否応なく言葉の柱を
英語から日本語に
シフトせざるを得なくなったと
でも しばらくは当然その柱が
不安定になったんですね
その結果 言葉だけじゃなくて
思考とか記憶そのものが
不安定になってしまったんじゃないかと
そういうふうに 私は考えています
つくづく 言葉と心の関係というのは
デリケートだなというふうに考えるわけですね
さて 話はここでは終わりません
私は５歳で帰国して
幼稚園の年中さんに編入したんですけれども
その後小学校に進んで
この小学校に行くときに
家が学区のはずれにあった
ということもあるんですけれども
登校班というグループで
子供の足で 15分から20分ぐらいですかね
歩いてみんなで通っていました
で この登校班の中で 私は
ほとんど喋らない人だったんですね
この頃のことは すごくよく覚えています
で まぁ なんて言うんでしょうかね？
その時 別にいじめられていたとか
嫌なことがあったとか
そういうわけでは全然なくて
ただ私が勝手に喋らなかったと
自分でも「自分は喋らない人間だなぁ」と
「でもこれは どうしようも
ないことなんだなぁ」というふうに
意識していたことも よく覚えています
で このような状況は
おそらく小学校の３年か４年ぐらいまで
続いたでしょうかね
今振り返ってみると この状態は明らかに
５〜６歳のほとんど喋らない期間
これの延長線上に
あったんじゃないかと思います
この後 小学校時代 私はほとんど英語の
フォローアップみたいなことはしなかったので
一旦 私の中の英語は
根絶されたというんでしょうかね
ほとんどゼロ近くにまでなりました
でもそのおかげで
日本語が中心となって柱になって
言語的には安定したんだと思います
ただ この「自分が喋らない人間である」
という認識というんでしょうかね
そういう心地というのは
その後もずっと残ることになりました
例えば今 私はこうして
カメラの前で喋っていますけれども —
まあ喋れと言われれば 喋りますし
教員だから当然授業は
喋らないとできないんですけれども —
ただ別に喋らなくても良いんですね
全然 問題ないです
時には 喋らないのが楽だな
と思うことも今でもあります
私がこうした経験を踏まえて言いたいのは
喋れないということを
甘く見てはいけないということですね
もともと言葉の使い方っていうのは
その人の個性が 大いに出るんですけれども
特に喋るということに関して言うと
その人の一番どうにもならない部分
どうしようもない部分
変えられない部分が出る可能性が高いと
それなのに例えば 英語のことでいうと
オーラル英語のトレーニングなんかで
「シャイだから喋れないだけさ」とか
「間違いを恐れなければ大丈夫
どんどん喋ろう」っていうように
激励だけして喋らせようとするのは
ちょっと安易じゃないかなと 私は思います
喋れない人に 無理矢理喋らせようとするのは
比喩的に言うと
筋肉とか骨格を 無理矢理引っ張ったり
ねじ曲げたりするのと同じで
暴力的な行為になる可能性が
あるんじゃないかというふうに私は考えています
もちろん 本当は喋りたいのに
喋れないっていう人もいると思いますね
特に英語のことで言うと
日本語と英語の
構造的な違いのこともあって
なかなかうまく喋れないと
そういう場合は —
きちんと こう —
技術的な問題ですから
例えば 発音の練習をするとか
リスニングの鍛錬をするとか
あるいはアクセントについて
きちんとシステムを学ぶとか
そういうことをすることで ある程度は
カバーをすることができると思います
でもそういう時でも とにかく
「シャイなだけだから
やってみれば大丈夫」とか
「間違いを恐れなければ大丈夫さ」
というふうに
なんでもかんでも
一種の無根拠な精神論みたいなものを
持ち出すのはどうかなと思うんですよね
シャイに見えることも
あるかもしれないけれども
それは単にシャイなだけとも限らない
つまり
日本語とか日本文化の
一種のルールというか 縛りがあって
そのせいで 喋れないってこともあるんですね
なので むしろそこをきちんと
筋道立てて説明した上で
練習していくようにすれば
そういう問題は解決できるんじゃないかなと
そういうふうに私は考えてます
さて そろそろ冒頭の問いに戻りましょう
私は先ほど 問いを立てました
「そもそも 人前で上手に喋るって
そんなに大事なことですか？」
「そもそも喋るってどういうことですか？」
そういう問いを立てたんですね
で この問いに答えてみたいと思います
まず 喋るというのは 言語活動の一部で
他の活動と切り離すことができません
それから そもそも言語活動というのは
人間の精神の土台の部分を成すところで
言ってみれば 人間が人間であるための
一番大事な本質的なところを成す
そういうものです
その一部だけを切り離すのも
おかしなことだというふうに私は思います
そもそも人と話すといっても
そこには聞くこととか 黙ることとか
そういう要素も入ってきますし
目配せとか ジェスチャーとか
それから相槌とか
呼吸みたいなものも絡んできますね
また 喋る時には喋りながら考えるとか
場合によっては躊躇するとか
さらには感じるとか
そういうことも関係してきます
ところが最近 どうも私たちは
人前で上手に喋ることが大事っていう
考えにとらわれすぎていて
喋るという部分だけを パフォーマンスとして
いわば チョキチョキと
切り取って特権化しようとする
そういう傾向があるように思うんですね
で そのうまく喋れる人っていう枠に入る人を
そこにスポッと入ることで
ちょっとしたスーパースターとして
扱おうとしたりする
でも例えばTED Talks で
18分間上手に喋ったからといって
それだけで その全人格が
折り紙つきになるかというと
どうなんだろうと思うわけです
実際には 人間は分からないところだらけです
複雑で多面的です
たとえ上手く喋れても
そこに見えていない部分というものが
必ずあります
私だって TED Talksで18分喋って
それで全てだと思われたくないですね
誰にでも分からない部分 見えない部分
っていうのがあると思います
ただ 私たちは そういう分からない部分 —
人間の陰影に満ちた
分かりにくい部分っていうのを
分かりやすくしたいんだと思うんですね
分かりやすく喋ってもらうと
まるでその見えない部分が見えてしまう —
見えるようになるかのような気がしてる
確かにそうすると安心なんですよね
何を考えているか分かんない人っていうのは
ちょっと不気味で なんか怖い
下手すると邪悪にさえ見える
ということがあるかと思います
ただ 果たして
そんなふうに 全てを分かりやすく
しちゃって良いんだろうかなぁ
という気が私はしているわけです
そして もしこの
TED Talksっていうイベントの中に
そういうふうに 全てを
分かりやすくしてしまいたい
というような考えが潜んでいるんだとすると
ちょっと私は そこが
気がかりだなぁと思うわけです
果たして 人間とか世界っていうのは
そんなに分かりやすく
とらえてしまって良いんだろうかと
そういう疑念があるからですね
小説の中にも
話し方に特徴があるという人は
結構出てきます
つまりその話し方を中心として
その人の人格造形がなされると
ただそういう人は
あんまりメインキャラクターとか
主人公にはならないですね
メインキャラクターとか 主人公っていう人が
喋り方だけを特徴にして
造形されるっていうことはあんまりないと
なんでかというと
小説っていうものの土台のところに
人間は表層だけでは
全ては分からないという
そういう一種の覚悟みたいなものが
あるんだと思うんですね
そういうことだけとってみても
小説っていうのは
非常に今の社会で読む価値が
あるものじゃないかと私は考えています
とはいえ このように
TED Talks に対する疑念そのものを
イベントの中に取り込んでしまえる
TED Talksっていうのは
さすがだなぁと思いますね
これはおそらくTED Talks そのものに
「人前でペラペラ喋れるのは素晴らしい」
っていうような理念だけでは推し量れない
何か深い奥行きのようなものがあると
そういうことじゃないかと思いますね
今日私がこうやって お話しさせて
いただいたというこのことが
まさに その証拠となるんじゃないか
というふうに思ってます
そういう意味では
改めてTED Talksそのものに
私は拍手を送りたいと
そういうふうに思っています
本日は お話を聞いてくださり
ありがとうございました